>>> WE ARE HEARING MORE AND
MORE OF PRO-LIFE ACTIVISTS
WHO'S BEEN TARGETED BY THE FBI.
NOW PRO-LIFE LEADERS CHET
GALLAGHER RECEIVING THE SAME
TREATMENT. THIS IS BECOMING
MORE OF THE SAME FOR BIDEN'S
DOJ, WHERE DO WE STAND ON ALL
THE ATTACKS ON CRISIS PREGNANCY
CENTERS AND THERE IS OVER 70 OF
THEM? JOINING ME NOW IS MIKE
HUCKLEBEE, FORMER ARKANSAS
GOVERNOR AND JACK BREWER, CEO
OF THE BREWER GROUP. GOVERNOR,
WHY DOES THIS ONLY SEEM TO GO
ONE WAY?
>> IT IS REAL SIMPLE, RACHEL.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO
INTIMIDATE AND NOT JUST THE
PEOPLE WHOSE HOMES ARE RAIDED
WITH GUNS DRAWN AND AN OVER
KILL OF ANY NECESSARY KIND OF
FORCE, THIS IS INTENDED TO SHUT
DOWN PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND ME AND
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OTHER
PRO-LIFE CHRISTIAN PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND TELL US
THAT IF WE DARE RAISE OUR VOICE
TO STOP THIS HORRIBLE SLAUGHTER
OF UNBORN CHILDREN, IT COULD BE
OUR HOME. WE ARE GOING TO BE
SINGLED OUT AS THREATS OF
DEMOCRACY. THERE IS BEEN NO
ARRESTS MADE AND NO RAIDS AND
THERE IS BEEN 107 DIRECT
ATTACKS AT PREGNANCY CRISIS
CENTERS. NO ONE IS BEING
ARRESTED FOR THESE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE COULD
CARELESS THAT THESE PLACES ARE
BEING FIRE BOMBED OR VANDALIZED
AND PEOPLE BEING THREATENED
WITH ASSASSINATION.
>> IT IS WORSE ON THAT, THEY'RE
SITTING ON VIDEO TAPES THEY GOT
FROM THE PREGNANCY CENTER AND
THEY REFUSED TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT. IT IS FULL-OUT AND
POLITICAL PERSECUTION. JACK, I
WANT TO GET TO YOU BECAUSE THIS
WEEK THERE IS A LOT OF NEWS
BEING MADE WITH FORMER KANYE
WEST, YE, HE TALKED ABOUT THE
RACIST ROOTS OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND HE TALKED ABOUT
THE KKK INVOLVEMENT. WHAT I
FOUND INTERESTING WERE ALL THE
THINGS HE HAD TO SAY ABOUT
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY. I WANT TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT IT BECAUSE I
KNOW THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO YOU.
>> THE MEDIA RIDICULED ME FOR
GETTING THE HOUSE NEXT DOOR TO
KIM TO SEE MY CHILDREN. AND,
THEY SAID I WAS STALKING HER
AND HER NEW BOYFRIEND BECAUSE I
BOUGHT THE HOUSE NEXT DOOR TO
SEE MY CHILDREN.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HIS
OVERALL MESSAGE ABOUT MARRIAGE
AND KIDS AND BEING A FATHER AND
BEING A BLACK FATHER?
>> IT IS SO IMPORTANT THESE
DAYS, KANYE, DELIVERS THAT
MESSAGE THAT CREATES A STIR.
AFTER THE DUST SETTLES, YOU
REALIZE THE SPIRIT THAT HE'S
COMING FROM AND THE BIBLICAL
CONTEXT WHICH HE'S STANDING ON
AND I THINK IT IS BEAUTIFUL FOR
A BLACK MAN TO BE IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT WHEN WE
HAVE SO MANY FATHERLESS KIDS
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY TO
STAND UP FOR HIS CHILDREN,
FRONT AND CENTER AND BE UNBASH
FULL ABOUT THAT AND MAKING THE
INVESTMENT OF TIME AND MONEY
AND RESOURCES TO MOVE NEXT DOOR
TO HIS CHILDREN, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT HIS MOTHER
HAD NOT DONE NECESSARY THINGS
WITH HER DAUGHTERS. RIGHT NOW
WITH THE CRISIS WE HAVE IN OUR
COUNTRY, THE PRO-LIFE MESSAGE,
THE CHRISTIAN MESSAGE, WE ARE
ALL BEING PERSECUTED RIGHT NOW
IN THE NAME OF JESUS. WE ALL AS
CHRISTIANS KNOW THIS DAY IS
COMING AND SO I THINK IT IS
TIME FOR US TO CONTINUE TO LOCK
ARMS AND BE EVEN STRONGER AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE THAT
WE ARE VOTING FOR AND THE FOLKS
WE ARE PUTTING INTO OFFICE ARE
FOLKS OF GOD. MEN OF WOMEN WHO
ARE GOING TO STAND UP FOR
SCRIPTURES AND BIBLICAL
CONTEXT, THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
WE'LL PUSH FORWARD IN THIS
NATION RIGHT NOW AND GET THIS
COUNTRY BACK ON TRACK.
>> YEAH, GOVERNOR, YE, ALSO
TALKED ABOUT BEING A CHRISTIAN
IN THIS MOMENT OF PERSECUTION,
SAYING I WAS BORN FOR A TIME
LIKE THIS. YOU ARE A PASTOR,
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE LESS POWERFUL THAN
KANYE WEST AND OTHER CHRISTIANS
FEELING THAT PRESSURE IN OUR
CULTURE RIGHT NOW.
>> THE MESSAGE DON'T CURL UP IN
A FETAL POSITION, GOD DOES NOT
GIVE US A SPIRIT OF FEAR. WE
NEED TO STAND UP AND LOCK ARMS
AS JACK SAID SO BRILLIANTLY
WITH OTHER CHRISTIAN BELIEVERS.
THERE ARE CATHOLIC
BELIEVERERS
WE NEED TO SAY THINGS
HORIZONTALLY. THIS IS A FIGHT
BETWEEN GOOD AND EVIL. IF YOU
BELIEVE IT IS OKAY TO SHRED A
BABY IN THE MOTHER'S WOMB RIGHT
UP TO THE MOMENT OF BIRTH,
THAT'S NOT A YOU POLITICAL
SITUATION. WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE SALVATION OF OUR CULTURE
AND CIVILUATION.